so you you do do great promos but um
i made a promo video do you want to see
it
put your headphones on you're gonna dig
this one
this is pretty cool
you're gonna like it
all right here's my uh promo video are
you doing blackface no no no
i just you know just wanted to show you
this is awful i mean oh my gosh
oh my god you can't dance look at those
tits
i'm gonna vomit his poor wife he's a
wife god
look at his little peepee this guy's
definitely racist right
he probably stinks too hey tom segura
you've been dancing your whole life i
know
show this fool
[Music]
wow
[Music]
where should we
[Applause]
[Music]
that was crazy but i was kidding you're
my best friend
and i love you
watch me
throw it back
there it is i made a dance video
it's the best thing i've ever seen to
start your day
really it's so good what kind
red kool-aid is [ __ ] awesome it
really is awesome
[Laughter]
it's so good take a little portal
something for yourself
is what it's watered down it's not too
bad you really drink it it's cool
it's cold yeah
you are drinking kool-aid yeah yeah yeah
it's awesome
you're drinking a [ __ ] 64 ounces
[Applause]
so much sugar
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're like good for that guy he drinks
a lot of water
oh [ __ ]
that's so much good that's half a gallon
of kool-aid
you're like i'm getting my day started
i'm sweating right now
i'm soaking [ __ ] wet
that's the hardest i've ever seen you
it's the hardest i've left
okay hold on it's pretty good it's not
that
it's good right it's good you should
drink
64 ounces
oh
sick
oh my god i'm crying and sweating right
now i'm gonna
[ __ ] throw up oh
you know how like you you don't realize
how different you are until someone
points it out
oh my god i need to i need to [ __ ]
lay down
your eyes are so bloodshot right now
love it
i don't know there's another
adult man in the country that's so
[ __ ] talented
getting fired sucks more than anything
than anything it is the worst
[ __ ] feeling in the world i got fired
once
i was working for a shopping cart
manufacturer in uh
in college and i was working for the
marketing division for a [ __ ] person
okay
wait you're gonna have to [ __ ] set
over
oh
oh anyone's got corona i just
oh my god
[Laughter]
i swear
that just caught me off guard the way a
joke's supposed to
this happened recently yeah like you
were on tour
before you start this story i need to
know that could i have gone
to jennifer aniston's house with you if
i had been in town
possibly
dude this i can't hear the story like
okay go ahead
let me hear it i get a call from my
agent and uh
we've been talking about a couple of
things and he says um hey would you be
interested
possibly in a
a movie where you uh
play a part with jennifer aniston and i
go yeah of course
okay and this role is you are you're
serving her sundays
i'm like what's your used car i go what
is it and he goes
he goes it's he goes uh it's not it's
not
um it's more like a comedy drama hybrid
and i go
can i know more about it he goes well
actually she
wants to tell you about it and i think
we're going to do
a like a zoom thing right because it's
during quarantine
and he goes she's got a new house do you
are you comfortable
going to her house and i go yeah yeah
yeah i go of course
so he goes all right so he puts me in
touch with her assistant
and they tell me all the information i
better assistant's hot as [ __ ] that's a
guy
so is he still off he's pretty hot so
i go to this house open the gate and i
walk and i think that the assistant will
greet me at the door
hold on hold on a second you go to this
house yeah you hit the buzzer so you're
on the street right i'm on the street
and then i i hit the buzzer what car did
you drive uh my
uh sedan okay you're going to jennifer's
house you know drive the [ __ ] i don't
know that's a horse so i i i just
anyways i walk up she dated brad pitt he
was totally into cars
right so i but i'm also i'll tell you
this i have i have some
anxiety you know you should have
something and i'm like
did you eat before you went not a lot
not a lot i'm a little honest i'm a
little hungry
so but i'm also like you know how do i
act right so
i'm like i'm like i'm being more jovial
than i actually feel you know i'm like
yeah
so i walk i i walk up and
the door opens and i go hi
i go i'm tom and
she goes i'm rachel
and i go what and she goes i'm rachel
from the from the hit television show
friends
so i think like we're doing a bit now
you know and this is how she's greeting
me
and i'm like this is a real story
so i go okay i go
i go all right i'm like yeah i i go
i i'm very familiar i don't know what to
say so i'm like
that's a good show i don't i'm like yeah
yeah
so i'm like is this i got i go like
sometimes know you feel like you're a
comedian so someone's like this is my
joke
yeah and i go i go
yeah and we're in her doorway so
the door's not even closed yet we're
both standing at her door and i'm like
okay
i didn't know if she's gonna like make a
joke now yeah and she's just looking at
me and i was like
i go yeah and she goes do you know ross
and i go he's your brother
she goes not everybody knows that and
i'm like i don't know what the hell is
going on
so i'm like yeah
i go yeah yeah because uh uh i go
i'm familiar with chandler two and she
goes oh you know him
and i go from the show
yeah and she's like yeah and then she
starts to turn
down the corridor like the hallway and
she goes
do you know phoebe and i go
yep she goes phoebe
i go that from the show the hit
television show
friends yeah and she goes that's
actually played by an actress named lisa
kudrow
and i go what the [ __ ] are you doing
i'm [ __ ] lost i'm scared now yeah and
like we're about to turn a corner so i'm
i stopped because
everything inside of me is like you
should get out of here like this is not
[ __ ]
yeah and i go what i actually said what
the hell is going on
what are you doing i said what are you
doing yeah and she turns back to me and
she goes it's called acting
and she turns around she walks down the
hall
i just made that whole story up you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you said you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ]
you're such a i [ __ ] you're such a
[ __ ] i believed
all of this do you know why because you
told me you said the tracy morgan thing
like there's no way i could make that up
so i go i wonder if i could make up a
story
by the way that's a good story that's a
that's a
that's an okay story okay
god damn it i really just sitting here
going like you're like this is a [ __ ]
yeah let's make a vow yeah that if we
ever meet jennifer anderson we bring
each other
okay and then do we tell her this story
no
oh i say we uh
let's meet jennifer aniston why don't
you put out
because i know you have a little buzz
going put out a message that we can
send to jennas and about meeting her for
real okay
look into your camera go ahead
hey jen it's bird chrysler
see you soon i froze i froze it's all
right i froze
i froze i think she should i'm good i'm
good yeah she might have definitely
collected
hey jen it's burke chrysler i'm here
with tom segura uh both of us have
netflix specials i
already [ __ ] it up all right let me
start again hey jen
comedian god damn it i'm [ __ ] this up
it's all right hey i'm not brad pitt
hey okay here we go here we go here we
go here we go rachel what's up
i had a great time i had a great lunch
and i really want to move forward
with what we talked about let's go back
and forth ready yeah um you go to your
camera i'll go to my camera and then
we'll go back and forth
and then we'll cut a sizzle and then
what do we want out of this do we just
want to do like brunch with her or her
house yeah yeah i mean it's kind of it's
kind of
like you know presumptive to say we have
to be at your house
you know what i mean like we just want
to how about we just want to have lunch
we're not coming to my [ __ ] house we
can't fit all
well i'm just saying though we can't you
can you know to to is meeting someone
is meeting and if you guys want to meet
you at your house well everybody's got
to be at her house or your house
okay do we invite her to your house sure
no we go to her house
okay how about we say we bring our wives
no
she can can she bring a dude for safety
now that sends the wrong message we're
dangerous you should protect yourself
we understand that you might feel
threatened in our presence so if you
want to have a couple security people
there it's a good idea
[Laughter]
my pants
[Laughter]
if you're around us you might think
you're going to die
so bring breakfast
every safety
can we come to your house
little people there
for safety
you should protect yourself
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go yeah all right
pick it up at the top yeah uh-huh yeah
uh
uh here we go
47 years young they call me the machine
party heart at night spin classes mickey
mantle gene every time oh you like that
though you like that okay here we go
uh-huh hitting the road in the tour bus
champ giving out chest stamps
i don't think there's any rapper that
talks about the travel channel
what happened i read travel channel and
i'm like
no no no no can i do them no no let me
do the lyrics
that's a good one come on
stop coughing with the coven sorry
i'm not even gonna look at him okay but
you gotta [ __ ] for real rap
i'm gonna go beforehand i'm gonna
perform yeah okay
okay turn my headphones up man
47 years young they call me the machine
party hard at night spent class
in the morning with the mickey mantle
gene hitting the road on the tour bus
champ giving out
chest dams quit working for travel
channel
now it's 44 and i'm on my second sword
out
sold out world tour here we go body
shots first birdie boy
second ending up in moscow st petersburg
chain
checking san jose sac town and
bakersfield taking off my shirt so you
know i keep it real oh yeah
so the girls put get [ __ ] feels not
racist not even a little bit i take that
back
i'm not a fan of inuits never met one
but i really
want to three months ago i got drugged
by a jew
two kids three dogs and a cat full head
of hair
nah that's just [ __ ]
i'm sweating so bad
you're a lyricist wait tell me